[Musik]
andere herzlich willkommen meine torten
würdest heute möchte ich endlich mal
wieder cupcakes machen und zwar habe ich
mir jetzt ganz besondere cupcakes
ausgesucht die kugel kennen
wahrscheinlich alle von euch
ich liebe diese kugeln ich mag einfach
die kombination aus schokolade und
haselnuss und deswegen sage ich heute
einen schokoladen cupcake machen mit
verlegung kugeln weil es nicht unbedingt
für kugel mag kann natürlich auch
austauschen durch andere pralinen oder
sie ganz weglassen dann habt ihr
allerdings nur show cupcakes ihr könnt
dann zum beispiel auch für küsschen
nehmen dass sich aber allerdings auch
mit haselnuss oder vielleicht die
lottokugeln da würde ich auch anderen
eventuell sind etwas abwandeln dass es
eher mit den zutaten etwas mehr passt
jetzt zeige ich einmal die zutaten für
den teig oder zeigt euch dann wie es
weitergeht
für den teig braucht ihr 100 gramm
butter die ist immer warm das ist auch
ganz wichtig 100 gramm zucker 1 125
gramm mehl 25 gramm kakaopulver und vier
teelöffel natron ein viertel teelöffel
backpulver und eine prise salz wenn ihr
kein natron da hab ich das nicht schlimm
dann eben die einfachen halben teelöffel
backpulver und ihr braucht zwölf
pralinen das sind diese roche von
verehrung
zuerst gibt ihr jetzt eure weiche butter
in den rumtopf und danach noch das jetzt
bei stufe 6 weiß cremig schlagen und
gibt dann nach und nach den zucker mit
dazu
[Musik]
dann sieht es in etwa so aus und dann
kommt da jetzt noch dass ein mit rein
und wird schön eingerührt
da fange ich jetzt bei kleiner stufe an
und geht bis auf die letzte stufe dann
sieht es so aus
und hier nebenan verhör ich jetzt ganz
kurz die trockenen zutaten also
kakaopulver mit mehl und den betrieb mit
und dann kommt es hier einfach komplett
mit rein und das wird jetzt einmal
angerührt
da fange ich auch klein an und gebe es
etwa auf stufe vier
einfach so dass die trockenen zutaten
jetzt schön mit der butter masse
verrührt werden
[Musik]
vorhin habe ich vergessen bei den
zutaten zu erwähnen dass ihr eventuell
noch ein schluck milch braucht oder
buttermilch das gebe ich jetzt nicht
rein
einfach das eine schöne rührteig masse
entsteht
[Musik]
und so sollte die masse dann in etwa
aussehen nicht zu fest aber auch nicht
zu flüssig und jetzt habe ich hier schon
meine muffins form vorbereitet
da gebe ich jetzt jeweils sondern großen
teelöffel teig rein
[Musik]
unternehmt ihr euch diese vereine roche
kugeln taxi aus und steckt sie jeweils
in die mitte und so einen muffin
[Musik]
dann gibt ja einfach allen wieder für
tag nochmal auf die kugeln drauf da
gibt's dann eben einfacher wenn der teig
etwas flüssiger ist aber dass da wird
auch so die kugeln umschließen
das ganze kommt jetzt in den ofen bei
175 grad ich schätze mal so 20 minuten
und danach zeige ich euch das ergebnis
so sehen die machen jetzt ausländer aus
dem ofen rauskommen ich habe es jetzt
etwa 23 minuten
hier stehen lassen dann könnte denen
sich hier ganz gut raus nehmen ohne dass
ihr euch die finger verbrennt und dann
lassen wir sie abkühlen und damit es
schneller geht werde ich das auch so
eine maus kita machen und ihr könnt
jetzt auch ganz deutlich sehen dass der
teig die roche kugeln verdeckt hat und
richtig schön gleichmäßig aufgebacken
ist für das frosting braucht ihr nur
diese drei zutaten und zwar sind es 60
gramm butter 120 gramm frischkäse doppel
rahmen stufe und 120 gramm nutella und
alle zutaten haben die gleiche
temperatur nämlich zimmertemperatur
zuerst wird jetzt die butter schön
cremig gerührt
das mache ich einmal auf höchster stufe
[Musik]
und dann gebe ich da jetzt einfach die
anderen zwei zutaten mit rein und lasst
es einmal schön geschmeidig führen
[Musik]
die creme fühle ich dann in meinen
spritzbeutel und bevor ich jetzt auf
spritze gebe ich sehe noch mal in den
kühlschrank damit sie etwas fest werden
können und damit die butter etwas fest
werden kann und stand kann man da die
creme besser aufspritzen ich jetzt hier
vorne so eine stelle aber ihr könnt
natürlich auch eine runde titel neben
oder eben eine tolle die euch besser
gefällt das schlag ich jetzt so um da
oben habe ich noch nicht raus gedrückt
kann es einfach so in meine form
zurückgeben so im kühlschrank stellen
und dann läuft da auch nichts aus eine
creme jetzt noch mal etwa eine stunde im
kühlschrank und jetzt kann ich sicher
schön auf spritzen und da könnt ihr
jetzt so viel nehmen wie ihr möchtet
ich mag dass er mich nicht zu verbringen
und falls ihr diese frisch christ
frischkäse creme nicht mit dann könnte
auch einfach mit garage neben oder die
muffins einfach so lassen das sehen
machen sind und keine cupcakes und
werden möchte kann da noch etwas
haselnuss krokant drauf heben das passt
ja ganz gut so roche
und wer dann noch lust hat kann auch ja
noch eine rote kugel oben in die mitte
setzen allerdings müsst ihr dann
bedenken dass dann schon insgesamt 2
rutsche kugel drin sind und das ganze
dann eben auch etwas süßer wird wie
gesagt dekorierte so wie er das möchte
ich denke ich dass sie so ohne roche
kugel die würde ich auch es kurz vor
verzehr drauf setzen damit sie einfach
noch schön frisch bleibt und so sehen
dann die fertigen cupcakes aus wenn ihr
die cupcakes nicht sofort zu werden dann
stellt sie bis zum verzehr in den
kühlschrank dann kann die creme noch mal
schön fest werden
ich hoffe dieses rezept gefällt euch
seid kreativ tauscht die rutsche gegen
andere pralinen aus zum beispiel gegen
raffael
dann würde ich da etwas kokosraspeln mit
den teig geben
wie gesagt hoffe ich dass es euch
gefällt ich freue mich über keine
kommentare und überbewertungen und dann
sehen wir uns im nächsten mal wieder mit
einem neuen video ihr dürft euch auch
weiterhin wie immer gerne rezepte
wünschen
die versuche ich dann immer auch im
umzusetzen und dann sehen wir uns bald
[Musik]